المفاوضات اليمنية حول ملف
الاسرى والمعتقلين. هولندا تتحضر
الزلزال يظل الموت اقرب اليه لكن
هذه المرة بسبب الكوليرا الذي
الخلافات بشأنه في البيت
الافريقي. مؤكدة استمرار اديس
ابابا في استكمال سد النهضة.
توجه وفد اللجنة الوطنية لشؤون
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقتحمت
جنين وقتلت اربعة فلسطينيين داخل
كوريا الشمالية لوقف المناورات
في المنطقة. من لم يمت بسبب
الاوروبية لتعويض الدعم
لاوكرانيا. لننتقل نحو ساحة اخرى
المتاريس المضادة للدبابات على
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا والطرق
الكامل بحماية الكيان الاسرائيلي
وحماية امنه من اي اعتداء. ها
الضيقة. الاحداث تطورات. دعت
المتحدثة باسم الخارجية الروسية
بينما ادان الهجوم الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بيان رسمي معربا عن
تقدم كبير في اراضيها بحسب
نافوستي. وفي خضم هذه الحرب التي
فلتنظر لفلسطين كما ينظر الغرب
لاوكرانيا ولا تهرول للتطبيع.
الصواريخ بشكل عام يصعب
اعتراضها. فهل هو اعتراف امريكي
مسبق بالخسارة الاوكرانية. اما
مدير وكالة المخابرات المركزية
امريكية. واعين الامريكيين شاخصة
نحو التنين الصيني ليصدر تقرير
ثمانين مليار دولار للاربع سنوات
التالية. بحسب بوليتكو فعن اي
فرحان الذي اكد ان بلاده مستعدة
للوساطة لانهاء الحرب الاوكرانية
بالانسحاب من باخموت بسبب نقص
امدادات السلاح متهما وزير
مركبتهم في بلدة جبر لتتوعد
الفصائل الفلسطينية برد موجع.
في مجال الاسلحة النووية وتعميق
علاقاتها مع روسيا لترد وزارة
الصواريخ التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة
الصوت ليس مفاجئا ايضا. وهذه
لكنه اضاف لنرى استعدادا جديا من
الجانب الاوكراني للحوار. وهنا
يحدث من ازمات ملتهبة في المنطقة
بحسب الوزير السعودي. جاء ذلك في
ثلاثة وعشرين شخصا حتى الا
تستحون يا تجار الحروب الم يحن
واللي على رأس بطحة يحسس عليها
كما يقولها المصري وبشأن مصر
الخارجية الصينية هذا التقرير
تحريف واضح للحقائق ومليء
تفشى بين نحو واحد وخمسين الفا
في مخيمات الشمال السوري مع وفاة
الخارجية الاثيوبية تتحدث. نهر
النيل نهر افريقي ويجب حل
اوكرانيا. حيث حققت سيول طفرة
هائلة في صادراتها للاسلحة لعام
تدور رحاها بين الروس والاوكران.
ورغم عدم تصديرها رصاصة واحدة
الروسي ان قواتها وجهت ضربة
انتقامية واسعة باكثر من
وفق شبكة سي ان ان. ليضيف كيربي
ان عجز اوكرانيا عن اعتراض
بالذخيرة. بينما هنا محطة زبروج
اصبحت من دون كهرباء. وذلك بعد
الوقت بعد لتنتهي حرب سورية
وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية تعلن ان
التي تؤثر على كل دول العالم لا
سيما في منطقة الشرق الاوسط وما
الاسرى التابعة للحوثيين الى
جنيف للمشاركة في جولة جديدة من
غارة روسية استهدفت مدينة خركيف
ومحيطها. لا تتوقف يا رفاق. فهل
الفين واثنين وعشرين اذ ارتفعت
بنسبة مائة واربعين بالمائة
ماريا زخاروف الولايات المتحدة
الى الرد بشكل بناء على دعوات
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف ان
بلاده ترحب بالوساطة السعودية
هجمات مستقبلية؟ المد الصيني
يرعب واشنطن. رد صيني مع كل خطوة
الذي يغذي المحطة. لتتهم كييف
موسكو بانها تضع العالم على حافة
بالفعل هناك آآ تصريحات آآ آآ
مستمرة من قبل مؤسس قوات فاغنر
الكونجرس تمويلا كبيرا المحيط
الهادئ لعام الفين واربعة وعشرين
الاستيطان ومنع عنف المستوطنين
ومحاسبة الجناة. وكيف يتم
بحوالي خمسة عشر فاصل ثلاثة
مليار دولار. وبواقع اكثر من ضعف
محاسبتهم بعد ان اعلن وزير
الدفاع الامريكي عن التزامهم
بالافتراءات. لكن الولايات
المتحدة لا تتوقف. ومن اجل
قلقه البالغ ازاء تزايد العنف في
فلسطين المحتلة مطالبا بوقف
الصفقات بذكاء حيث لم تعادي
موسكو ولكنها باعت اسلحتها للدول
البيت الابيض جون كيربي يقول ان
نظام الدفاع الجوي الامريكي
مواجهة الصين في الخمس سنوات
المقبلة طلب البنتاجون من
للحرب حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع
البولندي بدء جيش بلادي نصب
ما طلبه لعام الفين واثنين
وعشرين. ليصل المبلغ نحو اكثر من
الخدمة العسكرية ليصبح الجيش
الاوكراني امام مشك في التعبئة
عن الاستخبارات الامريكية يزعم
ان الصين تعمل على تطوير قدراتها
بشكل قاطع الانضمام للجيش وبعضهم
يلجأ الى طرق عدة للهروب من
العسكرية في الوقت الراهن وفق
صحيفة نيوز ويك الامريكية. وهناك
لاوكرانيا اصبحت كوريا الجنوبية
اكثر المستفيدين من حرب
المؤدية الى البلد الجار. فهل
وصلتهم معلومات استخباراتية عن
فالجيش الاوكراني يبحث عن مجندين
جدد. حيث ان الاوكرانيين يرفضون
الامريكية فاكد ان الاشهر
الاربعاء الستة المقبلة ستكون
باتريوت لن يساعد اوكران في
اعتراض الصواريخ الروسية المجنحة
وصولا الى مستوى قياسي بلغ سبعة
عشر مليار دولار لتتعامل مع هذه
انفاق نتحدث وما كل هذا الرعب
الامريكي من اصحاب العيون
لاوكرانيا. لكن ما هي الاسئلة
المعلقة يا هذا? ساجيبكم انا.
حاسمة بالنسبة لاوكرانيا. حيث
سيتمكن الجيش الروسي من تحقيق
يقاتل بها? اليس كذلك يا اصدقاء?
وبالعودة الى المعارك
مجموعة فاغنر هو من يطبخ هذا
الامر. حيث قال ان قواته مهددة
اربعمائة صاروخ ردا على التوغل
الحدودي للاوكرانيين. عن اي ضربة
وصلت الرسالة؟ نعم وصلت. وها هو
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجي في
من هدنة قادمة لتأتي الاجابة من
وزير الخارجية السعودي فيصل بن
تتضح تساؤلات بوريل فكيف يغدقون
كييف بالسلحة? اليس هناك من
ظل زيارة للوزير السعودي في
تأكيد على ان العلاقات السعودية
الاوكرانية. قالت الادارة
العسكرية في خركيف ان خمس عشرة
ذخيرة كييف اوشكت على النفاذ
فيما الدعم الغربي سيتوقف. فهل
الروسية متصاعدة وفي تطور كبير
خلال الفترة الحالية ليقول وزير
غريب امر هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا.
فتارة ينسحب الاوكران من
بعد توغل مجموعة اوكرانية في
العمق الروسي. لتؤكد الدفاع
جاء الخبر الصاعق بموعد نهاية
الحرب حيث قال الضابط المتقاعد
يتحدثون ليوجه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني خطابه نحو وزراء
ضربة روسية على المنطقة والتي
تسببت بقطع شريان الخط الرئيسي
روسيا اطلقت واحدا وثمانين
صاروخا وثمانية مسيرات على مدن
الروسي سلاسل التوريد لاوكرانيا
وسينتصر في الخريف. مضيفا ان
في الامريكية ان الصراع يدخل
مرحلته الاخيرة وسيسحق الجيش
عدة في الصباح الماضي لتبدأ
روسيا حفلة الانتقام الخاص بها
تزال معلقة. مضيفا ان هناك حاجة
لايصال حزمة اخرى من القذائف
الانسحاب بعد اقتراب سيطرتهم على
باخموت. ايعقل هذا طباخ بوتين
توافق على معظم اجراءات دعم
اوكرانيا ولكن هناك اسئلة لا
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قائلا هناك
مناطقهم. وتارة ينسحب الروس لكن
الاغرب هو ان تقرر قوات موسكو
بالامدادات العسكرية ان كان
البشرية او حتى الامداد
الاوكرانية وموسكو ترحب. وحفلة
الانتقام الروسية باكثر من
عسكريا بانظمة دفاع جوي ومليون
قطعة من الذخيرة. ليرد مسؤول
واثيوبيا تعلن التحدي من اجل سد
النهضة. الحرب الروسية تتوسع.
الدفاع الاوروبيين المجتمعين في
السويد. راجيا منهم دعم بلاده
اربعمائة صاروخ. والولايات
المتحدة تعلن عن تجهيز ثمانين
والفصائل تتوعد بالرد. الحوثيون
في جولة مفاوضات جديدة وحاسمة.
كارثة نووية بحسب وكالة الصحافة
الفرنسية. الجيش الاوكراني ان
طباخ بوتين يفاجئ العالم بشأن
باخموت. ومحطة زابوروجا تتلقى
الدفاع الروسي وجنرالات سياسية
اخرى بالخيانة. اليكم المصدر.
ضربة صاروخية كادت ان تتسبب
بكارثة نووية وكييف تطلب مليون
يفغينيا بروجيجيجن آآ آآ يتهم
فيها الدفاع الروسي بالتقصير
مليار دولار لمواجهة الصين خلال
الخمس سنوات القادمة فقط. وبكين.
مستفيد من الحرب الاوكرانية وقمة
سعودية روسية لانهاء الحرب
قطعة سلاح. فما الذي يجري بينما
كوريا الجنوبية تعلن نفسها اكبر
انتم تفترون وتزورون الحقائق.
وكارثة اخرى تصيب السوريين بعد
الزلزال. وجرائم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تتواصل في فلسطين
كساح محتملة للحرب القادمة. فهل
تتوسع الحرب ام ان وارسو